[Musik]
der bucht mit gernot hassknecht der
neuen armuts- und reichtumsbericht
erschienen im volks verarsche verlag
wirklich die ideale lektüre für alle die
wie ich gerne wütend einschlafen ähnlich
gute laune hatte ich nur bei dem
fotoband tabulose omas aus dem
erzgebirge ihren kampf und natürlich bei
erdogans neuem rezeptheft 50 dollar auf
ideen mit siege der armutsbericht kommt
mit anderthalb jahren verspätung aber
dafür wie immer liebevoll frisiert und
geschminkt komplett aus der
ursprünglichen fassung gestrichen wurde
zb das unter kapitel 1 wird von
interessensvertretungen und lobbyarbeit
ja das ist leider raus weil da ging es
um den einfluss von
interessensvertretungen und lobbyarbeit
will doch keiner lesen so deprimierend
sei ebenfalls gestrichen
die ergebnisse einer studie die
nachweist dass es für arme viel schwerer
ist einfluss auf politik zu nehmen als
sie heute hier verweise ich gerne auf
veronica ferres neues buch warum
heiraten die armen nicht einfach auch
dass maschmeyer
diedorf aber meine absolute
lieblingsstadt aus dem geistigen armut
spricht ist die hier zitat nur wenige
kinder in deutschland leiden unter
erheblichen materiellen entbehrungen
das heißt dass sie zum beispiel nicht
mal jeden zweiten tag nur für dünger
freund kriegen und das im schweine
reichen deutschland deshalb kann ich die
alte schwarz leider gar nicht empfehlen
und für meine lesetipps lauten diese
woche später als bayers
mittelstandsbauch in nur 56
frühlingswind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
prof